hello and welcome to this video playing
cast or again Grandmaster shrewd of
where I recently i won two games and so
we'll see it seems to believe in the
tirage defenseman he played Knight f6
last time check yeah this is a bit of a
slightly cynical line where black gets
wear black gets an ending which is just
slightly slightly worse it's it's not
much but white is slightly more
comfortable with black never winning
ever unless wide it drops dead off and
blunders a piece something like that i
should i played 95 your form and played
this a little bit too tingly
yeah it's not not an action-packed
position yeah i mean the deadline is
it's just very safe and white sometimes
can can can press a little bit but not
the way it went in the game I don't have
anything at all um came this one it's a
bit bit lame but I cannot I cannot
really do anything in it's just just an
equal position
I guess it should take you three year
see it's 94 something for white I don't
know doesn't look threatening
check check hmm well this ending is just
just slightly worse for black I don't
know why he goes Chad I thought it
slightly was so black maybe I'm wrong
that that's possible of course but I
thought he rather has issues with this
deep Anya then that then I mean okay
it's equal yeah I'm not saying I'm bad
of it I mean black is definitely not
winning or trying to win so what to do
there was a stupid idea why do i why do
I allow him to before it wasn't
necessary at all
m no that wasn't a very at all
huh Jeff just didn't didn't pay enough
attention in this position and stupid
very stupid play yakkung before what
else
I don't like to play this passively but
hotel else what else to do King they yes
I still think I should do this I
actually cannot go King be one this is
this is a problem but okay look here for
a tempo and then go to be one okay this
should should be enough check
I just need to trade a little bit Yellin
this is it then then it's enough I just
stopped the a pond I just need to need
to trade off the King side and it's a
draw yeah Brad and I just played a bad
ending here shouldn't get into any
trouble like that in the first place
look at 5i check here think what why is
that possible ok ok ok we takes with the
rook at the end but this is a draw jack
still so let's let's see if I i can just
attack on the fifth-ranked their time
morning and I'm winning the porn just
rook just this one right and 44
draw Harvard draw a third game I thought
he would play work against Luke yeah I
didn't mean it was a very stupidly
played ending a a4 was Lou yeah okay I
mean this is a this is an equal position
i was just too surprised that he went
for it because I thought is absolutely
nothing that I can do it it was it was
justified because i played this
thoughtless completely midas move a for
i can just stay in group d aid or
whatever but i thought okay it doesn't
matter but i simply blundered this check
and here i might be I might be losing
somehow yeah this is this mate made
sense to me this might still be a draw
my king is stopping this and I just have
to trade three against two on the
kingside check can now I think it's a
draw all along I mean maybe not at the
beginning I don't know we'd win up just
when i played a forward i think
somewhere around here should draw this
it's a bit slightly clearly covered I
don't think I should lose huh amen okay
I draw at the end I'm glad that I didn't
spoil this route ending completely okay
thanks for watching